- Bro, do you know how many
people watching right now
were scared to ask out the person
that they were most attracted to
and thus missed out on the opportunity
of marrying the person
that they most were in to?
That's life.
You don't ask, you don't get.
You got your perspective.
(engines roaring)
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(slow R&B music)
("Rush Hour" by Ely)
We're on the way to this
fireside chat with Ken Auletta.
It's advertising week here in New York
which means there are thousands of events
for the ad world going
on throughout the week.
Bunch of our leaders are
doing a bunch of events
and I'm doing one as well.
To give you macro context vlog,
we have a new person filming.
Why don't you say hello?
- Hello (laughs)
- [Gary] What's your name?
- Josiah.
- [Gary] And Josiah,
you excited to be here?
- Yes, more than anything. (laughs)
- [Gary] Good, so Josiah's excited.
I'm only here on Monday,
the Jets lost to the Jags yesterday
so I'm super pissed.
Congrats to Jacksonville.
I'm only here today.
I'm in London the rest of the week
so I'm trying to cram an
entire week into a day.
So I'll be rolling until midnight tonight.
Now, I'm running to do this quick event
and so that's where I'm at at this point.
This event will probably
be the meat of this episode
because you haven't been
able to film quite a bit yet
'cause so many internal meetings,
just operating the business,
one of the vulnerabilities of the vlog is
I talk about being the
entrepreneurial CEO operator
of my companies but
you don't get to see it
because so much of it is
sensitive information.
You're getting a first-hand look day one
of how much can't be filmed
but that's where we're at.
("Rush Hour" by Ely)
- [Gary] Yeah, no worries.
- [Leonard] My name is Leonard Armato
- Hey Leonard.
- A friend of mine
represented Shaquille O'Neal
for many years.
- Amazing.
- And has been really
good friends with him.
- Amazing.
- I watch your stuff.
- Thank you, Leonard.
- I don't know how you have the time
to do all those videos
everyday, how do you do it?
- It's just prioritizing.
To me, especially being
in the creative field,
I think being a practitioner of the craft
that you're trying to
get people to understand
is powerful.
I didn't grow up in it,
you definitely didn't
and yet, we couldn't do
the same things Apple did,
or Nike did as individuals, but now,
with distribution being commoditized
or changing, I think it's important
for me to understand the context
of creating and distributing
content with an agenda.
No different then what I
would require, want, target,
and so I prioritize it is the real answer.
I think people still view it as secondary
or nice to have and I believe
that a lot of the people here,
for all of us, the vulnerability becomes
when you get so far away from the reality
of the end-consumer we're
sitting in an ivory tower.
I grew up in using
marketing and advertising
to build a family business.
- I saw.
- For me, the way I view it is,
unless I'm putting in the
time to actually create,
distribute, write copy, edit, think,
then I'm vulnerable to being the thing
that I think is the most
vulnerable in the ad world now,
which is a lack of understanding
what's actually being
consumed by the end consumer.
So, it takes a lot of time, but to me,
there's three meetings I'm
probably having every weekday
that are less important
than I think they are.
- Yeah.
- That if I can allocate
that to content creation
and distribution and understanding
of the end-consumer's
thoughts will make me better
in the other 19 meetings
I'm in that are meaningful
with a point of view,
a strategy and understanding.
("Rush Hour" by Ely)
- Fifteen, twenty years
ago, you know or so,
advertising told you
what you're gonna wear,
- Yes.
- What you're gonna eat,
- Where you're gonna vacation
- Yes.
- And what car you're gonna drive.
- 2018, with all these movements going on,
all this spiritual going on, it's changed.
Now, the advertisers are reacting.
- Yes.
- You, as a key guy in
the middle of all that,
- Yes.
- are a great guy to talk
to about all of that.
- Thank you.
You know, I'm gonna be honest with you,
I think if you go back
to 1960s or the 80s,
a company, an advertiser, or a brand
that was advertising was doing it right,
they also were reacting AKA listening.
I think the difference today, you, I, him,
everybody watching, well,
they can make the content
that we listen to, so it's more visual,
but if you go back to ,
"Just Do It" or "Priceless"
or "Where's the Beef"
or the Jolly Green Giant
the strategy and insights
that led to the creative
were imperative.
They did it in focus groups,
they did it a different way,
but I would always say the
best talking AKA advertising
was always on the back
of the best listening.
I just think that all
of us can see the way
that brands are listening now
cause it's in all our faces
and everybody's producing.
- Talk to me about how
Hollywood, athletes,
all different walks of
life are coming together
and their voices now are being heard
where the advertisers are listening,
as you saw with the Chase spot with
the Serena and the US Open.
- I think the biggest difference today,
than let's say, Babe Ruth or
Mickey Mantel or Joe Montana
days is humans can now,
celebrities or any human,
can go direct to the
consumer and they don't need
an editor in the middle, they
don't need Walter Cronkite
in the middle, they don't
need ESPN in the middle
and what that's doing is
changing the distribution
and message dynamics in
a way we've never seen.
So, yes, whether you're
Beyonce, or Serena, or LeBron,
or a politician or an actress
on a hit Netflix show,
you've got leverage now
that we've never seen before
because of Instagram,
Facebook, YouTube and Podcasts
going directly to the consumer,
not having a middle man filter
you, stop you, or package you
in the way that they want.
("Rush Hour" by Ely)
- Your thoughts on your
Podcasts, your videos,
which I really like,
have given me what I need
to kind of take some of these chances.
- Good.
- I mean, I have a great
gig and I'm in a good place,
but I'm also trying to
feed that creative spirit.
I was an entrepreneur for many years.
- And to me, I'm sure you
must have picked up on this
why it's resonating, it blows
me away how young I think
you and I are.
- Yeah.
- And I think.
- I listen to that a lot from you.
- And I think that is confusing
to you and I normally.
- Yeah.
Cause we work the industry
with, but that's--
- I think it's important
and it makes me so happy
because it means a lot to me.
I just don't think, I don't know,
we've got 50 fucking more years.
I don't know why people think
it's over or a tail-end.
And I get it, I know why,
because we've been putting
in work for a long time,
but that makes me happy that it resonated.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- I appreciate, man.
("Rush Hour" by Ely)
- One of the fasting growing ad platforms
is owned by Amazon.
- Yes.
- Where do you see them in the future?
- Destroying everybody's face.
(audience laughs)
- Explain.
- If the government doesn't stop Amazon,
it's disproportionately the
biggest company in the world.
They are, the level of respect that I have
for the merit of the
skillsets of their executions
and how Bezos has run
that company pissed me off
because I'm like, "Shit."
I always rely on, "Well, I
still have 40 years to execute,
to do my thing."
Man, they have, it's unbelievable to me
how good of a company
that is and here's why
and it is absolutely why I think
any level of success I've had in my career
has been on a very similar principal.
They're outrageously pro their customer.
Amazon's winning because you love it.
Prime is like oxygen.
(audience laughs)
Everybody buys everything on it
and then they layer
entertainment on top of it,
don't even want to get into
the fact that "Sawdust"
is one of my favorite business concepts,
which is selling a
by-product of what you do,
which they've done better than
anybody with Amazon services.
They built all that
infrastructure for themselves,
then they sold it to the world.
I mean that company has
just done so much right,
it's uncomfortable.
- You can make an argument
that no one has better data
than they have because
they have the online search
which is what you're interested in
or Facebook which you and your
friends were talking about,
they have ads which you purchase.
- Yeah, I mean, they are--
- How do you see them using advertising?
- Easy, when that data goes to the web
and they share, sell,
or leverage that data,
What's amazing about Google
is it's intent to buy.
What a lot of very
educated people here know
is that Google ads are extremely strong,
even against Facebook,
if you're talking about
sales intent in a
short-term, whereas Facebook
is crazy and why I've been
surprised the ad world
hasn't embraced it more, is building brand
on top of funnel.
People misunderstand
Facebook in our industry.
They think of it as more
of a direct-to-consumer
strength place, Facebook
is absolutely the platform
that has replaced
television for the ambitions
we have for television,
which is creating above the
funnel, top brand awareness.
What Amazon has is the cleanest data
you can see about buying,
'cause it's not even intent.
I want to buy scissors,
on a Google search is a really good data
if you sell scissors and then
you put ads in front of them.
But actual data that you bought scissors,
that really matters and
so, when you think about,
their ambitions and I think
people are very naive.
I don't think people
understand what happens next.
I think, for example, this is really wild
because I saw all the
branding, I'm convinced
that Target is in deep shit
and that they have no place
in the world of retail
and either Facebook or
Amazon will buy them, right?
And so, I don't think people
realize the retail wars
that are--
- Why would they buy them?
- Well, because what
Facebook has to understand
because I think Cheryl
and Mark are super smart
and what Google has to
understand is that Amazon's
retail leverage is unbelievably important
to the advertising world
that we all live in
and I think I would be stunned
if Target isn't sold to
Facebook, Amazon, Google,
or maybe even Apple.
I would just be stunned
because it's a pillar
that the rest of them are vulnerable to.
To Amazon and it's data
and execution and leverage.
- Thank you.
- He's gonna be late.
- Just want to get a quick
photo with you please.
- Okay, Gary.
(smooth, confident music)
- I'm so flattered that
people appreciate my work.
- [Josiah] Mm-hmm.
- I mean, I don't think
people, I mean, I will never,
to the day that I die take for granted
that somebody wants to
take a selfie with me,
that is like, so flattering.
You know, even hearing
you say, "You're Gary V,"
when I'm aware of what's going on,
they will never be my soul.
- [Josiah] Yeah.
- I'll never be Gary V in my soul.
- I'll always be (indistinctive)
who's like six years old
and can't speak, you know?
- [Josiah] Right.
- There is no, I'm not
capable of going there.
I can't get over that hump and
become a caricature of myself
or somebody I'm not.
- [Josiah] Yeah.
I just wasn't parented that way.
- I just wasn't brought up that way.
My experiences don't give
me the ability to sell out.
- [Josiah] Mm-hmm.
- That' it.
- [Josiah] That's awesome.
- You know?
- [Josiah] Would you say
that a lot of it has to do,
you say with parenting, would
you say that a lot of that
has to do with just the fact
that you're able to do that.
Like being that--
- Grateful?
- [Josiah] Grateful, yeah,
to be in this position?
- It's also things I put on a pedestal.
I think it's cooler for
you to tell your cousin
in seven weeks that Gary V is a real dude
than I think it is of me being so cool
that I have no time for nobody.
- [Josiah] Mm-hmm.
- That's what I think is cooler.
- Yeah.
- I think being nice and
a good dude is cooler
than being too busy for somebody.
Some people don't.
Some people think cool
is being unavailable
and bigger than them, like,
so, it's my own ideology of
what does winning look like.
- [Josiah] Got it.
- You know?
- Oh my God, nine years ago,
I retweeted something and you
did a random act of kindness
and sent flowers to my house,
okay, which was like a fun,
you should've just sent flowers, you know?
You did a whole riff off of it.
I was like, "Oh, my God,
I got the fucking flowers,
this is awesome."
- Was this when I said you
should send flowers not just on--
- That's right.
- On Valentine's or birthday
- So when Camalig told me he
was going with you to Vegas,
I'm like, "Oh, yeah yeah,
he sent me flowers already."
- I just got relayed for the
UN project I told you about.
- Good for you my friend.
- So it's gonna be massive.
- Makes me so happy.
- God willing, it's gonna be really huge.
- Good for you.
- I thought, really you
could be a nice (indistinct)
- I hope so.
- I think you'd make a good one.
- Thank you guys, I'll talk to you later.
How many sneakers did you buy
to have this five minute thing?
- Uh, 35 pair.
- That's fucking ludicrous.
Like, the fact that you paid $3500
for all this awareness is laughable.
So, if I'm hackable,
everything is hackable.
Like, this is meta in itself.
Like, for two seconds I was
promoting this opportunity
and you were the smart fucker
to take advantage of it.
- (laughs) Yeah, I mean,
it's a lot of money,
but its a no-brainer.
- Dude, it's not a lot of
money for the exposure,
you're right, it's a lot of money.
I don't shit on 3500 and
most people don't have it,
but the fact that you can
repost the sneakers on eBay
and get $60 of it back?
(laughs)
And that's the point,
bro, if you're hustler,
you can do anything, right?
Like, you could spend all day, you could,
like this is your dream, you could spend
fucking 11 hours a day, two
hours a day, one hour a day,
dming 150 different
creators and being like,
"Yo, I'll give you a 10th
of a point in my company,"
we talked about this or whatever it is,
but it's just hacking moments,
right, it's just hacking.
- I put the video up of our meeting
on your First in Line
group and it went crazy.
The support was so cool, I mean--
- You mean the Facebook
group, First in Line?
- Yeah.
- The one that everyone
watching this should join?
Tell 'em, now I'm gonna
do a fucking commercial.
Tell everybody here how
ridiculously awesome
First in Line Facebook
Group is for the community.
- It's unbelievable, so
a friend of mine told me,
after she saw that I was on with you,
and I put it in there one night,
woke up the next day to like 100 comments
of full support, sharing that dot com.
I've had phone calls to start investments.
I've had phone calls making
connections, it's crazy.
Crazy.
- Good on good on good always wins, man.
Just fucking does.
Okay.
- Yeah.
- What else can I answer for you in this
kind of like your last
minute, your last leg.
I mean I think the growth
strategy is two fold.
One is that you go and hack
the community of Instagram.
Two, I think you take
this video, download it,
from the saving, and
just fucking email 950
investors and in the--
- Yeah.
- And in the title be
like, "Yo, here's my video
with Gary V, I want to sell
sneakers, but as you know,
this five minutes is not
a good use of my time
for those 35 pairs.
I did this the same reason
I do random podcasts,
which is I love when people leverage me
to create their dreams.
Beggars can't be choo--
(laughing)
- Yeah, bro, beggars can't be choosers.
You want a half a million dollars,
the only way you're
gonna be able to do it is
based on somebody believing in you.
What are you selling?
You have no data.
When you're in idea phase,
you're selling yourself.
Do you know how many
people watching right now
were scared to ask out the person
that they were most attracted to?
And thus missed out on the
opportunity of marrying
the person they most were into?
(laughing)
- I'm not sure.
- Period.
That's life.
You don't ask, you don't get.
- Are we doing another phone call?
- No, I gotta get out of here,
I gotta run to something.
- No, I wanna do one more, Gary.
- Okay, let's do it real fast.
- Let's do one more
because I feel like this
next kid, I used to--
- It might not be a kid.
- I used to be online and I felt like
if I don't answer, like the
next, can I miss out on--
- Let's go, here we go.
- So, I feel like this
next kid might be special.
I'm just feeling something.
- Who's the person you
were looking at on YouTube,
the person right before Justin?
- Oh, he was an artist--
- That's so amazing,
he went right into it.
- He was an artist that Akon had,
I can't remember his name.
(phone ringing)
- [Brooke] Hello, this is Brooke.
- Brooke, it's Gary
Vaynerchuk, you're on the
"Ask Gary Vee Show" with Scooter Braun.
- [Brooke] Hi, oh my God,
- This is --
- Brooke, before you do anything,
you need to thank Scooter
tremendously, I'm about
to be late for something,
he pushed me because he
has that kind of energy,
you need to really thank
Scooter for this moment.
- [Brooke] Scooter, thank you so much.
- This is it.
- [Brooke] My name is Brooke Johnson.
- We'll sign you.
- I have applied for an
internship with your company
for several years now.
(clapping)
- Brooke, this is the greatest moment,
Brooke you have made my fucking life.
Brooke, good news.
- [Brooke] No, you've made--
- No, Brooke, you don't even know,
you've got the job, it's done.
You've got the job, SB
projects, you're locked in.
It's done, it's done, I will do every,
I will cancel my life to
make this happen, Brooke.
You're an intern in for SB, it's done.
Brooke, I'm telling you, it's done.
- [Brooke] Scooter, I--
- Congratulations, no,
no, Brooke, say thank you,
Congratulations, Brooke, this is done.
- Brooke, Brooke, where do you live?
- Scooter, so I went to LA last week,
I bought a hundred dollar plane ticket
just to go down there 'cause I was like,
"Hey, I'm gonna get some coffee with CEOs
'cause no one's calling."
I live in Seattle, Washington,
actually Tulalip, Washington.
- Keep going Brooke, this
is the moment of my life.
- [Brooke] I flew down
to LA and I was like,
I'm gonna get some coffee with CEOs
because nobody was biting
on any of my applications
that I was throwing in.
- Yep, keep going.
- [Brooke] Sony, Live Nation, nothing.
- Keep going.
- [Brooke] And so, I got a few interviews,
but when I was down there,
I got pick-pocketed,
I got my phone stolen, I got
in a really bad car accident,
- Jesus.
- [Brooke] I was t-boned and
thrown into an intersection.
- Alright, Brooke, first of
all, I'm gonna give you money
for the rights to your story.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- I want this movie, keep going.
- Keep going.
- [Brooke] I had the
biggest interview of my life
the next day at 9am.
- Who was it with?
- [Brooke] It was with Adidas, it was--
- Okay, keep going.
- [Brooke] I signed an NDA,
so I can't tell you much,
(laughing)
It's was a big, big job and
I, so they interviewed me,
blah, blah, blah, but I
got an email last week,
and they're like, "Hey,
we're moving our offices."
So I was like, oh great,
I don't know what to do
and I want to work in LA.
- Brooke, I have a question for you.
What do you want to do?
- [Brooke] I want to change the world.
- I understand that, but--
- But in details, Brooke, don't
blow your fucking shot here,
with some fucking ideology bullshit.
- Okay.
- We're not ideology,
we're fucking life into
the wrong direction.
- Brooke, what kind of
job are you looking for?
- [Brooke] I want to inspire,
I'm looking for marketing.
I want to inspire people
to inspire themselves.
- Okay, Brooke, hold on, hold on.
- Brooke, you go one more ideology step
and Scooter's gonna kill
you and hang up on you.
Don't give me any more 2019 horse shit.
Get real practical here right now,
this is the moment of your life.
You're gonna watch this video every day
for the rest of your life
and if you do one more
ideological fucking
theoretical bullshit thing here
when he's looking for practicality,
I'm gonna punch you in the nose.
- Okay, Brooke, here's
my question for you.
You said marketing, what
gives you experience
in marketing, anything?
- [Brooke] I have a little
bit of marketing experience.
I was the president of the
American Marketing Association
at my university.
I successfully got us $7000 through--
- Don't worry, you're fine.
- I'm still here, Brooke.
- [Brooke] Through, I
didn't sell anything,
I just went to my Zumba class
and these women, I got these
women on board with my ideas
and they're like, yeah,
we'll give you some money,
and so I walked out of the
YMCA one day with $1000.
- So, I want to explain what happened.
Gary needs to go and Gary,
we just did a call with a guy
and I just said, look
my whole life experience
has always been that last
one, when I'm about to leave,
like answer one more, then
something very special happens.
So, we decided you were
the one special, I said,
"Gary, one more."
So, that's why he was
saying everything else.
What I'm saying to you is,
I get in a lot of trouble
with my staff when I
meet people in the street
and they ask for an
internship and I say yes.
I've literally-
- D-Rock is super pissed with me right now
'cause I just did it.
- I am actually told that
I'm not allowed to do
that anymore by my own company
because I get in so
much trouble giving ran,
and usually they turn out to not--
- Yeah, they're always shit.
They're always shit.
- [Brooke] Oh, no I'm a good investment.
- No, I know, but--
- Here's the thing
- It's always shit, Brooke.
- It's usually always shit,
but it's worked out a couple times.
- Yeah, one time nets out and guess what,
that's why Scooter and I have companies,
not the fucking henchman in the quarter.
- Okay, so I'm gonna get your information,
I'm breaking my rule, this
is not for any kid watching,
you meet me in the street, I'm
not breaking my rule, again,
don't get it twisted.
- This is never happening again.
- Okay, but what I'm gonna
tell you is I follow,
the universe has fixed
my life plenty of times,
I was telling Gary earlier,
when I don't really know,
sometimes it shows it for me.
You need a break and I
think sometimes in life,
I was talking to Gary--
- Brooke, start fucking crying.
- Brooke, I want to explain this, Brooke,
I was talking to Gary about luck earlier,
and what I mean by that is,
and I never got to explain it,
I have friends who I
know are as smart as me
and have worked as hard as me
and have not had the success
in life because along the way,
they just didn't get the
breaks and I always tell them,
"Keep going, the breaks
are waiting for you,
the breaks are waiting for you."
Sometimes it happens earlier
in life, I got lucky,
it happened early in life
and sometimes it happens later in life.
- And sometimes it happens
on "The Ask Gary Vee Show."
- And I think tonight happened
I don't know what it will turn into,
but you deserve a break, so
I'm not giving you a job yet,
but I'm gonna give you the internship
and what I'm gonna do is--
- We're gonna pay you
minimum wage, too, Brooke.
- But unlike the other interns,
I'm gonna actually make
sure that you and I,
that I put you on a couple projects,
to make sure that I see what you can do
on the marketing side
and that's why we did
the extra phone call.
- Brooke, Brooke, even
better, it gets way better
because I'm not letting fucking
Scooter here out-Oprah me,
so, on top of that, because
you want to do marketing,
I'm paying for all this shit,
I'm flying you to New York,
I'm putting you up in a hotel for a week
and or at D-rock's house, I
haven't figured it out yet
and you're gonna work
here, at Vayner for a week.
- What if I want to hire her?
- No, no, stick with me real quick.
You're gonna work with my team for a week,
we're gonna give you all the secret sauce,
so that when you go
back to Scooter's land,
you're not just doing some YMCA hustle,
you're doing 2019 perfect marketing.
You're coming here for a week,
we're gonna teach you as
much as you can in a week,
you're gonna work 19 hours
a day like our crew does,
then you're gonna go
back to Scooter's world
and eventually be the CMO of
fucking Scooter Braun Projects.
And Brooke, I'm gonna
buy you a $4,000 car.
- What are you, you're really open.
- I'm being dead serious,
you can't get to your
fucking office without a car.
I don't know what $4000 gets
you in car world these days.
- You want to split it?
- Done.
Brooke, we're buying you a $4000 car.
- By the way, my office
is gonna be really pissed
that I'm just giving out cars
and they've been working there.
- Listen.
- They're gonna be like,
"What the fuck?"
- Brooke,
I'm gonna hang up now, because
I'm about to buy you a house.
(laughing)
And so, congratulations, Brooke.
Brooke, we're buying you a
fucking car, you've got a job,
you work for Scooter,
you're fucking coming,
getting a IP from Vayner,
like shit's good tonight.
- [Brooke] Oh my God.
- Are you crying,
laughing, or throwing up?
- [Brooke] (stutters)
I'm doing smile crying.
- Awesome, love you Brooke.
Scooter, you're amazing.
- Take care, Brooke.
- That's why we do the extra phone call.
- I get it,
I'm not even doing a question of the day,
that was the fucking ending of the day.
I love you brother.
- Love you too, buddy.
- Always, I'll see you soon.
That was amazing, see ya bye.
(upbeat, r&b music)